everyone absolutely loves Chewbacca in
Star Wars I'd never met anyone who
doesn't I think we've got 50,000 people
here and I've seen most of them to there
today so you are corrected but you say
from little children to 90 year olds
they all work to eat and I don't gun I
understand more now than when we
actually did the movie because Chewie
has become a teddy bear he could become
a security blanket he's just grown now
it's three generations coming on four
and if you can't get a teddy bear to
last that oh he's a bad date
what we want to know is of course you
said people been asking you about the
future movies but and you don't and you
don't know I can understand that but
would you like to see Chewbacca make a
comeback Chewie back on the screen I
think I think Chewie will be wonderful
back on screen because humming got it
practiced for three movies four movies
now
Julie would be yeah he would be an
addict a would be one of those additions
that would be actually helpful to
everybody so yeah bringing back who
knows we will see we will be on the big
screen again once one day sooner the
better or as far as I'm concerned
because everybody's getting older and
you might we'll do it we've heard talk
of maybe people like Harrison Ford and
Mark Hamill and Carrie Fisher coming
back as well would you like to see those
guys back on the big screen - I loved
you know we have I think we had over the
three movies we had a good team
that was
that was
no not in agreement totally but most of
the time they were in agreement and at
the end of the movies they're all back
together ahead and that is the way it
should be
was it like wearing that outfit there's
quite some stuff you had on there it's
like going to Wimbledon today playing on
Centre Court and losing so yeah no it's
extremely extremely warm the only place
that it was suitable was when we were on
Empire in Norway so that was minus 15
and it was really cold but he added the
suit held up and I didn't get frostbite
or anything like that so everything
worked out extremely well
now when you look back over those three
movies and obviously everyone holds them
within such a fraction
what were your particularly strong
memories either of filming or particular
scenes that you had as I say the
Norwegian shoot was probably the worst
shoot that we ever had
and there's certain scenes one would be
install a new hope would be they've just
gave because you've got a chessboard and
there is nothing on it and you're
supposed to play chess so and I checked
with one of the technicians and he said
I said you know it's nothing honorable
he said don't worry about it
making out we'll put it in later and
that's what happened
you know it was there as I say that over
the years is too many too many scenes
and incidents that SEM seemed funny or
seemed serious at a time now you look at
them they're part of history
you